all right hi there everyone I'm Alena
and today I'm going to tell you the
linguistic backstory of the regular
expression regular expressions look
pretty intimidating
I mean imagine being a new coder and
seeing this monstrosity when I started
coding I was pretty freaked out by
regular expressions I just didn't get
them if I were a Shiba in you I would
look just like this some of you might
relate to that sentiment some of you
might wonder how you can get better at
writing regular expressions the usual
answer is something like Stack Overflow
but people tend to use Stack Overflow to
copy and paste code when they're in a
pinch rather than to learn the proper
way to actually write regular
expressions to truly understand regular
expressions I propose an unorthodox
route learn linguistics go do it right
now now I mean I'm being a bit facetious
and you know this is a big thing
learning linguistics what I really mean
to say is learn how regular expressions
work in the field of linguistics before
trying to use them in JavaScript this is
what I'll be walking you through today
let me take you on a journey that begins
with Noam Chomsky who's pictured right
here and and oh look at you cool Chomsky
fans in the audience me too
and this journey will start with Chomsky
and it will end with the regular
expression so as some of you may know
Chomsky is not a computer scientist by
profession he's a linguistics a
philosopher a political activist and a
ton of up a ton of other things but his
contributions to computer science were
pretty accidental his major contribution
to the field of computer science is
something known as the Chomsky hierarchy
the Chomsky hierarchy
is an ordering of grammars but since
most of us in the room are not linguists
we'll have to cover what a grammar is
before we can go any further so first
thing I'll take you through a linguistic
crash course so that we can understand
Chomsky's hierarchy so grammars grammars
provide the rules that build languages
some of you might also wonder what's a
language well a language comprises of
symbols and the rules to apply to those
symbols in other words languages
comprised of symbols and a grammar these
symbols can be combined to make strings
the grammar provides us with a set of
operations that can be used on these
strings symbols to be a bit more
specific grammars provide a framework
with which input or intermediate strings
of symbols can be converted into some
output string of symbols throughout this
presentation I might refer to input and
intermediate strings as non terminals
and output strings as terminals I'm just
telling you this now so that if you hear
these different terms you'll know that
they mean the same thing
so I want to make these terms feel a bit
more tangible because obviously learning
linguistics in two minutes is not a
thing that anyone can do so I'm going to
provide an example using a made-up
language from the world of Harry Potter
known as Parseltongue so in Parseltongue
there are three terminal symbols and
three non-terminal symbols they're right
here
in Parseltongue there's also a set of
rules for converting non-terminal
symbols into terminal symbols
so now let's go through an example of
converting a non-terminal string into a
terminal string so here is our starting
string it is a non terminal oops
I'm sorry one slide back this is our
starting string now I'm going to make
one conversion of the first non-terminal
symbol into a terminal symbol
however this conversion does not make
the entire string a terminal string the
string is still a non-terminal because
there are still non-terminal symbols the
words am and snake in there so with that
being said I'm going to make the next
conversion of AM into s the string is
still a non-terminal finally however the
string will become a terminal when I
turn snake into this SS so we just
produced a string of entirely
Parseltongue terminals which is
otherwise known as a terminal string
since we use the Parseltongue grammar to
create this you could call this a
grammatically correct phrase cool so now
that we've learned some new linguistic
terms I'm going to reintroduce you to
the Chomsky hierarchy
it looks quite like this in the interest
of time I'm going to hone in on the
regular grammar which is that innermost
circle so what is so special about this
regular grammar well in the process of
converting a non-terminal string into a
terminal string regular grammars have no
knowledge of the strings past States
once the regular grammar converts one
non-terminal symbol into a terminal
symbol the grammar essentially forgets
what the previous state of the string
was we care about regular grammars
because they are regular expressions I
mentioned a slide ago that regular
grammars retain no information about
intermediate steps in converting in
put string into an output string so what
does this tell us about the regular
expression the forgetfulness of regular
grammars implies that translations in
one part of a string do not impact how
non-terminals are translated in future
slaps this means that there's no
coordination between the different parts
of the string in creating the output
string this gives us some insight into
why programmers first brought regular
expressions into code because regular
expressions convert input string to
output string piece by piece
they're wonderful at pattern matching in
programming regular expressions provide
the rules to convert a pattern into the
set of strings that match that pattern
so in JavaScript this is what the match
method does it takes in the pattern
let's say it's called reg X like up here
and this pattern is a regular expression
and then match will find all sub strings
of a string which I've called s and then
match and sorry it will find all sub
strings that match that pattern within
the string s so the linguistic origin of
this programming concept that we know
regular expressions is starting to make
a bit more sense now one question
remains how else do regular expressions
in programming relate to those that
we've seen in linguistics thus far well
I'll walk you through their similarities
before their paths fork regular
expressions of linguistics and
programming use the same three
grammatical operations these operations
are alternation repetition and
concatenation I'll talk you through what
these three rules look like using both
words and then some examples alternation
effectively gives us this logical or
operation to understand alternation
I'm gonna tell you a great story it's a
true story about the 1920s when a lot of
Greeks were emigrating from Greece to
the United States my family was one of
those set of Greek people given that my
forebears didn't speak English it was up
to the immigration officials to
determine how their Greek surnames would
be spelled usually using the alphabet
that we use in English so some of my
relatives ended up with the surname calf
kiss spelled with es and then others
ended up with the last name calf is
spelled with is Lester family reunions
turn into something like these cats
which I'd like way aggressive don't want
that to happen I can use alternation in
order to create a pattern that matches
both spellings of my last name thus
pleasing everyone in my family which is
pretty cool so now that we've talked
about alternation we're gonna move on to
repetition repetition allows us to match
an expression 0 or more times let's look
at some bit strings in order to see
repetition in action all right so I have
this pattern right here in AB is 0 1
star what 0 1 star will match is 0 and
then 0 followed by any number of ones
the star is something known as a meta
character which is basically a shorthand
character and it symbolizes one one of
the many forms of repetition that you
can use in JavaScript all right on to
concatenation concatenation joins
expressions together in order to create
new patterns I think that concatenation
is pretty useful when we're trying to
see how matching different conjugations
and tenses of English verbs look so we
have this regular expression right here
it's called call will match many forms
of its infinitive to calls so it'll
match call calls called calling all
sorts of things but as soon as we add
another letter or another pattern to
that regular expression only calls will
be matched so yeah now that we've talked
through these examples of the rules that
both engineers and linguists use in
terms of regular expressions it's time
to discuss how regular expressions in
code and JavaScript in particular differ
from their linguistic predecessor
regular expressions in programming
languages have two major add-ons these
are back references and quantifiers once
again I'll talk you through these
differences with some examples along the
way back references allow regular
expressions to store these small
patterns or sub patterns back references
can be used to match all the laughing
messages that you send your friends and
I'll show you how so take for example
the humble word ha the pattern above
denotes ha as a sub pattern using those
parentheses and then references it using
the backslash 1 shorthand symbol this
meta character tells us to match for the
sub pattern again then the star at the
end matches the second ha repeated 0 or
more times so to put it a bit more
simply this pattern that I've written
here matches the string ha repeated over
and over again
one or more times I mean you can you can
test it out if you want but it might
just look like this right now a little
bit of force laughter but yeah cool so
some of you might notice something a bit
more disturbing about
back references and it is that they go
against the purpose of regular grammars
as it's spelled out in linguistics as a
reminder the purpose of regular grammars
is not to retain information about
previous states or previous places in
the string so despite the performance
hit that this violation will cause
programmers enjoy having a way to match
repeated sub strings under quantifiers
so quantifiers alter the greediness of
the regular expression matching what
does greediness mean here well levels of
greediness are measured by the
programmers answer to the question how
much of that one thing do you want let's
look at the star plus sign and question
mark quantifiers for some examples in
code alright we saw this example a bit
earlier when I was discussing repetition
if you'll remember the pattern 0 1 star
matches 0 and then 0 followed by any
number of ones the star quantifier
matches the expression to which it is
applied which is the 1 here 0 or more
times so I can contrast this with the
plus sign quantifier the plus sign
quantifier matches the expression to
which it is applied 1 or more times this
means that from the previous slide we
had 0 as a possible match whereas now we
do not and then one more quantifier
that's pretty cool to look at is the
question mark quantifier the question
mark quantifier matches the expression
to which its applied 0 or 1 times only
those two cases this means that the
pattern that I've written above only
matches 0 and 0 1 the star plus sign and
question mark quantifiers that I
mentioned are just a few of the many
quantifiers out there that JavaScript
programmers use quantifiers are now
because they give programmers more
flexibility to fine-tune their regular
expressions then the linguistic rules
allow for now the Sun must sat on our
linguistic journey through the land of
regular expressions even though the Sun
in Berlin does not set until 9:00 p.m. I
walked you through the path that regular
expressions traveled from Chomsky's
theory to JavaScript I showed you how
regular expressions differ in
linguistics and code all that cool
information aside I think that the most
important takeaway from this talk is
that regular expressions were put into
programming languages such as JavaScript
for very pragmatic reasons they were
also tweaked for practical reasons
learning about the linguistics behind
regular expressions helps us understand
why the people who brought linguistics
in the code made these very particular
design decisions this goes to show that
interdisciplinary learning enhances your
programming knowledge I encourage you to
seek out concepts that were brought into
computer science software engineering or
even JavaScript specifically from other
disciplines trace them to their roots
like I did today and you can deepen your
understanding of those concepts thank
you everyone
once again I'm Elena I work at a cool
company called medium and I love how
linguistics and programming intersect so
feel free to come talk to me about it
after this
[Music]